[Music]
in snapchat soccer news - by lure from
Manchester UK mmm
snapchats new snap map can share your
location with friends but this is a
possible safety risk for children of
course with a funny with the GPS are you
getting desperate because Instagram is
smashing your face all over the place
filters air filters away better oh for
sure but I rather just use one app now
it has just enough where Instagram wins
I just want my pretty so I haven't sent
a dick pic in like forever success so
like how do we how do we figure this out
like what is how do you know how for you
to know how can they accurate as a
pinpoint so I'm going to show you guys
is 45 seconds promo ads like snapchat
showcases their new feature thank you
I have all your sexual predators by you
immediately you pretty much alive your
birthday with you but really no no feels
come on
you printer you came up there you by
magic
oh not sure how 30 yet let's go
[Music]
[Music]
Wow Apple so you just going to invite
yourself these people do this I think
it's go it's rude so how does it work
when your friend posts then it gives
away their location so now you can be
like okay cool that's where they're at
so I can see where they're at sometimes
what if your friends don't want you
there exactly yeah my god you show up I
don't want Matt I'm at a funeral right
now I'll be right there that's that is
that like I'm at a funeral like well it
says on here that you're at some
nightclub in a strip club or whatever
oh my bad forgot to tell you I actually
don't like you yeah so the way the
future works is immediately it tells me
like do you want your friends to see you
like only your friends or everyone or go
in ghost mode and so apparently what
they're initially reporting is that it
immediately has you set up where anyone
can see you on the map and so people
have to like put themselves on in ghost
mode and so if you're not in ghost mode
then you can see yourself on the map and
so can anyone else whether it's your
friends or if it's everyone and then
it'll show even when you're on the move
I'll show you inside of a little Russia
I'm not sure exactly how I care it it is
on the map because it does show you like
the block seizure as a human it's like
you're really really sick kind of like
the Pokemon yeah okay we stop do G know
we knew that you're at home yeah so
another turn that [ __ ] off girl you
don't even need to have this [ __ ] on she
shouldn't be there yeah ninety percent
I'm sleeping no answers every time I was
checking my snap map you're the only
other friend that I had that like allows
me to see where you are be like Oh
Gina's at home you're like a minute two
days later Jane is at home yes Phil at
home huh yeah we didn't turn out often I
talk about that thing yet everybody
knows where you at girl yeah and then if
you see like right here they're like
shades of different colors it shows like
the concentration and how many people
are snapping in that area we like geotag
not everybody wants to be so connected
god damn it dude what's so wrong about
this [ __ ] being by yourself I
actually like this because um I want to
see what's happening around town and
then I can just like lurk there clerk
clerk clerk clerk and it's kind of fun
yeah it's actually a pretty fun when I
was playing with it too and then you can
see like across the world see what other
that I didn't know yeah if you like zoom
all really could see little what's
happening in Zimbabwe right now
Jonnie like zoomin oh what if people are
like recording stuff from the war and
then you could kind of like see war
footage live you still what is wrong
what if you look at North in North Korea
and there's just one little dude it's a
fat kim jongwan Tim picked up in bed
i'ma gonna shoot some babies so
everybody look at me everyone ate today
I would watch that I'm just saying if
North Korea I don't know hey I'm going
to capture somebody and not let them go
anywhere
well if you feel like this huge circles
with like whatever it says on it so
they're like major events that are
happening and you could click on it you
can see everyone and having to that so
worried everyone's wedding and you're
not invited
dude I'll be so cool man oh my god so
people have been report or not reporting
but they've been tweeting out that
they've been catching their significant
other cheating already on this map
because they could see like worker
boyfriend it's like they're showing up
to like another car feels like going off
so what you could share a location - on
the iPhones like an hour you could share
location on the iPhones I find my
friends I don't even like that [ __ ] -
because Muriel she's like oh we should
just share it to the location I'm like
nah I do it for safety hi
I don't know I don't like people
tracking me and she should know where
I'm at I said oh you know what all you
got to do if you want to know where I'm
at call me optica what did you get like
not disappear so you never took me
through at one point you let your phone
in the car for the whole entire day
while you were inside that's right
but either way she should know I just
don't think you need it because I'm not
a cheating cheating guy and I'm always
honest with my [ __ ] so I feel well she
wants it for safety purposes yeah I
don't how you defense it for no reason I
don't know I just don't like some my
tracking me you know saying I want my
bank checking it every second of the day
yeah no man so if you need to know I
think it's dope for safety reason I'm
saying like I do it because I don't know
if a guy's going to come up in a van and
take me away and in the only person
I couldn't askin because I'm famous and
she's not okay then like she could look
on the phone and then it's like oh [ __ ]
Joe's here I need to go help him and
then she could jump in one of my cars
and come rescue me I don't know what I
don't like it
like it makes complete sense that it's
you know for your significant other to
know where you're at and for your safety
purposes but for some reason I don't
like somebody coming back is the wanna
be loved
no I do you you probably don't think
anything's gonna happen to you but then
something's gonna happen to Harz well I
didn't did he say her location with you
she she would love to oh is it a to a
thing you can't just do one sided like
you could see where she's actually can't
see or hear I want to do both so we know
each other all the time I'm Italian so I
yeah I just like I don't like it I don't
know why because I'm ticular to myself
like people didn't have the [ __ ] before
things were okay but people also got
kidnapped and then couldn't get found
yeah ain't nobody got kidnapped but I
think somebody kidnaps a good luck
didn't she'll kick your [ __ ] ass play
fight so he hits me in the chest all the
time please don't kidnap her sharing
your location with friends [ __ ] my old
friend
not really yeah you don't need to know
what she had at all weeping at them
either in the country sleeping at home
worm somewhere in some [ __ ] [ __ ] off
my Nona's sleeping band in another
country sleeping there two people are
either at McDonald's or another's one
girl she's a good [ __ ] I would like
some [ __ ] import model she loves sharing
she was sharing her location everywhere
she makes a face with all public and
tags and tags for self at these places
and checks in I have a stalker and I
don't know why I'm so scared by the way
a nice little I'm gonna be there from 4
to 3 like dude did it [ __ ] stupid
dude let's get out here this is engine
severe well he doesn't have a sucker
we'll probably want the donor person
that's like that one guy that goes to
the boba shop and they're like oh I
don't know why there's all these fans
but hey it's gonna be a meet-and-greet
yeah
Wow Oh I'm going to be here from 4:00 to
8:00 working on my projects whoa there's
so many fans here what happened I get
any work done
there's too many fans coming I don't
know I can't I can't do it because I
feel like if I wasn't a public figures I
probably do it I probably cool with it
because it's like what I have five
friends yeah it's cool you know then I
get to see what they're doing who you
guys are at that concert I think this is
cool yeah especially if like am I also I
know Gina was in Germany and I'm like
looking and I'm like ah Nicole you don't
have to tell me about your trip I
already know I already seen that [ __ ]
wait so can you put it on friends only
mm-hmm they're good I think I think you
have it as oh really I was like a green
I hope so is that impossible because you
said it turns on tarmac we don't know
let me report it but when I turned to
mine on it automatically asked me what I
wanted to do so I don't know think names
is okay but you can check it because I
feel like it's more dangerous for the
girl because especially like if like
guys want to jack off to your pictures
all the time then they're going to try
to find you and jack off to you in
person but for guys like I feel like
even if a girl was kind of [ __ ]
herself while watching me it's not
threatening whether it's a guy trying
Jack I'll see if I was a female and I
saw that I think it's way more scarier
than like me waking up and then this is
a window washer just jacking off boys
watching the window and you're watching
me I'll be like dude what the [ __ ] man
you [ __ ] nasty ass I don't mind it so
much Jackie and ostomy as long as you're
across the street I just don't want
someone like standing on my grass and my
grass turns brown
but after across the street and they
have like a giant telescope they're
jacking off steam you know just open the
windows was given a free show Bart might
even bend over for them too yeah I
dropped my pawn shop
did you say drop your socks what if
they're hanging out to do well it
depends it depends is if she's okay with
there because I'm okay with it she's not
then I'll go hey don't do that don't do
that
any other like it dog okay great she's
always like that all the time at home
boom I like taking a shower with the
windows open it just feels yeah and then
so as soon as she comes in she's like
closing all the window how much money I
could make like this no she's like
closing all the windows I'm like no one
wants to see you naked and if they do
who gives a [ __ ] if there's a sex scene
no one wants to see me naked
okay let's say people want to see it
come on you girl you ever going to be a
porn star I'm thinking about it no
you're not
I want do nothing or gonna be able to
have done it before the baby right away
what no no there's milk for EM oh my god
you guys I will burn every copy of that
[ __ ] and delete everything on the
internet is pregnant porn though you
know that Lauren
let's pregnant women getting [ __ ]
actually I'm actually branch off sack
because I just pictured the baby going
and then she swallows it goes into the
baby no absorbs yeah
yucky they're just one when there's guys
like this and then she's just squeezing
milk in it yeah and I was like I wonder
what that tastes like but that doesn't
make me horny yeah it ate that came a
little familiar yeah we talking about
this you forgot it was coming all off
that's good yeah that's like the the
melona
put the [ __ ] we find you baby pretty
shitty oh stop one that is the same way
though like she's gonna um she doesn't
want me to be naked because the
neighbors can see but I'm like you're
more like you're thinking about the
neighbors before me like damn dude
also she was worried that the neighbors
are completely naked yeah all she's
worried about the neighbors I think
she's worried about you being seen by
the neighborhood who cares
either way I'm not the one worried
that's the thing so I'm walking around
my apartment and I'm naked and I'm like
this is my apartment she's worrying
about the neighbors and she's like they
don't deserve you that's a thing though
but she's still worth it it's like what
shouldn't I be the one worried like
whoever to put the current down that's
true I'm like nah because a counter is
perfectly angled to where it's below my
wings yeah so if I
by it perfect it is so weird I'm so far
away they can't see my dick
I want to going on they can use fans
hope you guys like that episode remember
to follow our personal social medias and
of course if you want to watch more
videos - you know where to go your [ __ ]
suckers right up there
[Music]